nobody ever tells you that like when you
get to the top there's nothing there
there's nothing
there there's just more of that if you
want it
you know i had ground and scraped and
fought to make movies and to make the
things that i wanted to make and to sell
books and sell scripts and i was doing
all those things and then i get there
and i'm like a broken shell of myself
with this relationship that threatened
to sort of like
truly like wreck my life and i had done
nothing to deserve that
and you know i'm like what
what is life like what you know i'm so
backwards
uh right you thought everything that was
gonna make you happy didn't yes
everything you wanted to do you were
doing but you still weren't happy but i
was you know but i'm i'm a victim i'm
i'm uh i'm a product i should say of
these systems that we all
survive in which is you know this sort
of capitalist driven
corporate uh corporatocracy kind of
driven
um way of
of merchandising and commercializing
every um thought and fear and moment
that we have in our lives and um and
never giving us a chance to slow down
and uh you know when when i was able to
i i
i was
on my way out and i saw my kids and i
saw them grown up
and
you really saw that yes i did
and um and i saw them asking me just
like like a mature grown adult would say
you know say something very calmly
without emotion like please don't do
this
it was such a
such a startling
image that you know um
you know them saying we need you um that
i i climbed up out of that i pulled
myself up and i i got out of that and uh
was it hard to get out of that i mean
thank god i work out because i mean if i
didn't you wouldn't have been having i
would try this together you know but i
did and um and uh you know so i got up
there
and did you just get hysterical after
that yeah
just like kind of lost your mind for a
second yeah like
this is where i am
what is wrong and this is after a good
year this is after making tons of money
this is after like this is after
accomplishing all the goals how c how
can that be
like that's not something we talk about
that that
that there's nothing there at the top
that like you know that life isn't
about you know jim carrey's said it
before you know i hope everybody gets
what they want and gets
the riches that their hearts desire so
they realize that there's no that's not
what life is all about that's not what
will make you happy
um you know some people have discovered
that truth and
so you talk about what inspired me
to start talking about something more
meaningful on my channel
and it was this realization when i came
out of that i called a doctor that i'd
never talked to i had a thera to shrink
in la
um who
seemed to be able to help people like
this you know it was advertising that
kind of thing and i said i need help
immediately like this hour
um because i don't know what's going to
happen right i'm out of my mind
and um
and i he you know he sees me and
you know he it was the first time i ever
heard the word bipolar in my name in the
same sentence he goes we took some tests
together and he goes okay you're bipolar
bipolar one and a little bipolar you
know and i was like i go sorry for
causing a lot of you know i swear i know
a lot of young people but you know uh
you follow me because of the stuff that
i talk about on my channel but i was so
pissed i was like you man and i'm
still a little i'm a you man i'm
not i'm not you and he was like
okay like he's probably done this a
thousand times with people right but i
almost thought you'd feel like a relief
like no you know what it is you want to
put me in a box you want to put me in a
little category especially a category of
like basket cases like you man i'm
hell is your initial thought right yes
dude i
no i resisted i resisted and then he
goes i think there's medication and like
you man i'm out and i left
i left and i like go down to the parking
garage and i'm like sweating and pissed
and
i know he's right you know i know he's
right
and i go back and i'm like um
i'm a little i'm having a hard time
dealing with this but let's talk about
what you know of this